ambulance workers have joined a long
list of public sector strikes driven to
Industrial action because of low pay in
the face of a crippling cost of living
crisis in this sector perhaps more than
most low pay has life and death
consequences
it hasn't invested properly in the
workforce and people are leaving in
their droves and it's one of these
cumulative things pay isn't good people
leave it means those who are left behind
are under even more pressure and too
often the ultimate price is paid by
patients according to NHS England the
number of patients who died while being
transferred to hospital in an ambulance
more than doubled from 40 in 2021 to 93
in the past 12 months the number of
patients who suffered severe harm in
ambulances triple to 154 and more than 5
000 patients came to some sort of harm
on their way to hospital
like their colleagues the nurses no
ambulance worker wants to risk Patient
Care by going on strike but what they'll
tell you here is that the ambulance
service has been risking patient care
for a long time what they want is better
pay that leads to Better Staffing levels
that leads to better care but as with
the nurses the government is refusing to
negotiate Beyond a payoff of four
percent well below inflation at almost
11 percent I think we're held together
by the Goodwill of our clinicians and
NHS workers across the country but it's
unsustainable it is a crisis and without
intervention from this government we've
got serious concerns for the future of
our NHS and health of a nation in
general the ambulance workers say
they'll win this fight even if it means
more strikes in the new year but an
improved payoffer they say will only be
a small step towards saving the National
Health Service they're proud to
represent Jonah Hull Al Jazeera at
London